well I'm very very saddened to hear of
this tragedy in the channel today
um waking up to the news that I fear as
the MP for Dover and deal day after day
lives lost a number saved only 43 saved
only due to the bravery and
professionalism of the Rescue Services
that operate out of Dover and along our
East Kent coast and I have I have to you
know pay tribute to their bravery and
thank them for their rescue mission this
morning in absolutely treacherous wintry
conditions
it must have been a horrific call out at
three o'clock wasn't it
um in terms of what the solution is what
would you like to see the government do
well as I've said now uh time and again
it is a matter of great urgency that the
boats have stopped entering the water
from France uh people are safe in France
this is illegal criminality organized
crime through and through that number of
people crossing now uh very near to 45
000 people that's the result of
industrial illegal immigration by
organized criminal gangs operating on
the shores of France it is urgent that
the Prime Minister who is taking
personal responsibility for this issue
has a summit with president macron and
that action is taken to bring this to an
end before we have further loss of life
in the channel
we spoke to Claire Mosley from the care
for Cali charity just a moment ago she
said one wait waiters get the boats to
not go in the water in France would be
to set up a center in northern France
and offer safe passage to those who who
believe that they have a strong claim
would that not be a solution
unfortunately organizations like care
for Calais are part of the problem not
the solution in dealing with the channel
Crossings care for Kelly is one of the
organizations that's taking legal action
against the government and is not I
think really looking out for those
solutions that would be in the best
interests of people who are in the hands
of these criminal gangs and often also
in crime here in the UK once they are
smuggled in and involved in modern
slavery and we've got to you know really
be clear that those organizations are
blocking the attempts of the government
to be trying to bring an end to the
small boats of Crossings it is vital
that they really look at the interests
of people in the hands of criminal gangs
encourage them not to take these
Journeys that are so dangerous and do
result unfortunately and sadly in loss
of life encourage people instead to ask
France for Refugee assistance if they
are in need of it or any other country
before they reach France who is party to
the same Refugee conventions and also to
make it really really clear that the
majority of people who have been
traveling by the small boats arriving in
Britain in recent weeks are albanians
from a safe country and who are not in
need of Refuge or Asylum and it's
absolutely vital that we take action and
bring an end to this and stop these
criminal gangs who are ruthless and do
not care if they are risking lives in
the pursuit of their illegal crime
do you dispute the figures that she
provided as we know that there is a a
particular problem with albanians
traveling across in recent weeks but the
figure that she quoted eighty percent of
those who reached the UK on these small
boats are actually granted Asylum
well we know that our system in the UK
is in need of Reform and the Prime
Minister yesterday set out his
five-point plan for tackling that which
included
though is that a as far as you
understand it is that is that a correct
representation of the facts that 80 of
those who have come across on the small
boats are eventually granted Asylum well
we know that once people are in the UK
it is extremely difficult to do anything
but for the majority of people to stay
in the UK and that is why it is such a
strong magnet for people to come in
through illegal routes and try to get to
Britain that's why we have to be very
very clear that illegal immigration is
not acceptable that we do have but we do
if I can finish but we do we do have
resettlement schemes that we operate
with the United Nations where we bring
people directly from conflict areas and
there are over a hundred million people
displaced around the globe the right way
to deal with Refugee and Asylum is to
make sure that we have the systems and
processes and support in place to help
people we do that as the Prime Minister
said yesterday more humanitarian visas
have been issued than since the second
world war we are a generous country but
this is about illegal organized crime
and if we want to help people who are in
need of assistance they should not be
taking this incredibly dangerous
Crossing we've seen lives lost again
today we've got to bring it to an end
but their point is of course that you
say that they are illegal but if 80
percent of them are granted asylum in
the UK it shows that they had a valid
case which therefore means that they are
not illegal they had a valid case for
Asylum and they would argue that because
there aren't the safe routes that
they're able to use they've been forced
to take this action
many Charities that any British
government had more safe routes than
they wouldn't have to get on the small
boats
there are safe routes of Entry we have
issued as the UK more humanitarian visas
than since the second world war there
are safe passage routes there are
applications for work visas which
hundreds of thousands of people take
there are education visas they're our
family reunion visas that you can apply
in the UK from a room and a computer in
the UK so no family member needs to get
into a boat or be in the hands of
illegal immigration illegal entry to the
UK is a crime it is not the way to come
to the UK the UK does have resettlement
and Asylum programs it does give a
tremendous amount of support around the
globe as well as to people who settle
here in the UK and it's absolutely vital
that those two issues are not confused
to do so just drives up more illegal
immigration we need to tackle this at
source and recognize this for the
illegal activity that it is that our
safe and legal routes to come to the UK
and people must take those they must not
risk their lives or indeed lose their
lives in the wintry sea in the channel